the climate emergency recovery from a
global pandemic
an assault by the uk government on the
powers of our own parliament
and the consequences to our economy
society and our place in the world of a
disastrous brexit that scotland did not
vote for
and yet despite the magnitude of those
challenges many of them global today's
politics can too often feel small
polarized divided
and incapable of meeting the moment
this agreement is intended to change
that in scotland it is about doing
politics and governance better
cooperation and collaboration in place
of division and acrimony is in my view
and indeed my experience what most
people want to see much more of from
their politicians
it is also essential if we are to find
the solutions needed to solve the
problems confronting the world today
and of course that spirit of cooperation
and consensus building is very much in
keeping with the founding principles of
the scottish parliament
our parties will of course retain our
distinctive identities this is not a
coalition and we do not agree on
everything but we are coming out of our
comfort zones to focus on what we do
agree on despite all of the risks
inherent in any decision of two parties
to cooperate more closely we are
choosing to work together and we are
doing so not out of political necessity
but for the common good
the agreement delivers bold policy
action on pressing issues
a commitment to more affordable housing
a better deal for tenants and action to
tackle poverty and inequality
steps to accelerate our transition to
net zero more support for active travel
transformation of home energy and a
10-year transition fund for the
northeast of scotland a focus on green
jobs and fair work and a sustainable
recovery from covet
and action to improve mental health and
reform public services including the
establishment of a national care service
we also in this agreement reaffirm our
shared commitment to securing
independence for scotland and to giving
people the right to choose our country's
future through a referendum
the agreement also sets out the
processes of cooperation and
consultation that will enable a stable
parliamentary majority for the delivery
of the scottish government's legislative
and policy programme
and as part of that for the first time
ever in uk politics it will see greens
enter national government as ministers
working in a spirit of common endeavour
mutual challenge and collective
responsibility to deliver for the people
we serve
now in the coming days this agreement
will be scrutinized by our respective
parties i will commend it strongly and
wholeheartedly to mine
but the publication of this agreement
today undoubtedly marks an historic
moment
it recognises that business as usual is
not good enough in the times we are
living through
it grasps that out of great challenge a
better world and a better scotland is
capable of being born
but it understands that achieving it
will take boldness courage and a will to
do things differently that is what we
offer i want to thank the scottish
greens for the constructive process that
has led us to this butte house agreement
today and see how much i hope that we
will work together in the years ahead to
secure the greener fairer independent
scotland that we know is possible
i know that's patrick and then lorna to
say a few words before we take questions
from the media patrick thank you first
minister this is indeed a historic
moment
this deal would see the greens entering
government
for the first time ever in scotland or
anywhere in the uk
and it couldn't come at a more important
time
the last 18 months have been an
incredibly difficult time for us all
and as we seek to rebuild our lives
we and our economy we really must seek
to do things differently we must build a
fairer compassionate country
and we must do everything in our power
to tackle the climate and nature
emergencies and deliver a just
transition for all of scotland
and that's what this deal will do
it means that our parties will be
working together to deliver a bold and
ambitious program to deliver a green
recovery from covid
a new deal for tenants and a fundamental
change in approach on transport
it will put two green menaces into the
heart of government
advocating for the climate and for a
fairer greener scotland
but fundamentally it's also a new
approach to politics the snp and the
scottish greens
are different parties we agree on some
things disagree on others and those
distinctive voices can and will remain
that's why this isn't a coalition in the
traditional sense
but that mustn't mean that we can't
cooperate
for the good of the people of scotland
our climate and our environment
to work together where we've got common
ground challenge each other to deal with
disagreements constructively
and yes to deliver a referendum on
independence when we emerge from the
pandemic as both of our parties pledged
to do
in the recent campaign
next week scottish green party members
will have the decision on whether we
take this historic step and i look
forward to engaging with them in the
days to come together we can and i
believe will make history
the un scientists at the ipcc last week
confirmed what we all already know from
the images of fires and floods across
the world
the climate crisis is accelerating and
we have to act now
the stakes simply could not be higher
and with the cop 26 climate conference
coming to scotland we are in a position
to show real leadership on climate
we need to cut scotland's emissions fast
here are three ways that this deal would
do that
one we would deliver a radical shift in
transport spending 10
of all transport spend would go towards
making cycling walking and wheeling safe
and accessible for all
and we would invest five billion pounds
over this parliament in scotland's rail
network
two
we cannot tackle the climate emergency
without improving scotland's homes and
buildings
we have therefore agreed an accelerated
and expanded 2.8 billion pound program
that would support everyone to make the
changes that we need over the coming
decade
three
we would accelerate the rollout of
renewables and double the size of the
onshore wind industry
creating thousands of good quality jobs
as an engineer from this sector i am
particularly excited about this
this deal is about people
as well as planet
together we would deliver a new deal for
tenants giving tenants more rights
introducing rent controls to help tackle
scotland's housing crisis
we would make bus travel free for young
people
create
a new national park
and much more
the scottish parliament was founded upon
the principles of accountability
democratic participation and equality we
as elected representatives must
constantly strive to
live up to these principles and it could
not be more important than just now
and that is why we are proud of this
agreement that we are publishing today
it's why we are pledging to work
together to build a greener fair and
independent scotland and it's why we are
recommending this agreement to our
parties